jason and john how nice you went to see
ronnie i i i must say
and to be honest with my audience jason
and um and john did say ronnie's house
is beautiful in las vegas but i did get
a report that you guys felt ronnie's
really starting to look his age what
about this
yeah it's just like i haven't not seen
him in over two years i i could see some
physical differences he kind of had like
a little old man shuffled to him and you
know it just dude
yeah i like like yeah
meanwhile
were you shuffling ronnie because you
were high or were you shuffling because
it's getting more difficult for you dude
i walk around with no problem i don't
know what the [ __ ] do i know the new
nickname for ronnie is ronnie chong
and
[Laughter]
it's also i'm very relaxed here that's
true he is so relaxed the place is great
he was a great host him and stephanie
are getting along great they have a
super cute dog who loves to party with
weed i see uh ronnie puppet has joined
us what's on your mind yeah yeah you
know
did you ever get so high from some of
that cannabis [ __ ] that you actually rub
the dog's ass all over your face it's
cool
come here peanut you got a dog now yeah
stephanie found this dog it was a rescue
uh when she was working at the animal
hospital here
and um she went to see the dog and next
thing you know the dog is living here
but the dog is great yeah you like the
dog what kind of dog
is great oh there's peanut with uh
there's peanut with ronnie puppet go
ahead yeah hi peanut peanuts at
chihuahua yeah
he had his balls chopped off
[Laughter]
yep he has his balls chopped off he's
got he's got a chip in him already he's
got everything he's got a chimney i got
a chip stephanie put a chip in you
ronnie is that right no not yet
so i don't want to
yeah so when i'm shuffling i might get
so i don't get lost